- Put my leg up as well
- Yeah.
- So I also look like I'm
- Yeah, please do.
- Really chilled.
- Just lay down.
Should we just lay down
and just spoon each other
the whole time?
(laughter)
- We'll just have a nap, just 20 minutes.
- Hi, I'm Gina, I'm here
with actor Aaron Paul,
and these are his Netflix nine.
- Netflix nine.
- How did you keep this a secret?
This must've been the
biggest sequel on Earth.
(chuckle)
Like seriously, because
everyone loves Breaking Bad,
and then you're walking
around with this secret.
- Yeah.
- Like you're pregnant with this new film.
- Yeah, I was very pregnant.
- Heavily pregnant.
- Overly due, it was great.
I dunno how we kept it a secret.
For me it was honestly, it was really easy
to keep my mouth shut.
I love lying to people.
- Oh, okay
- In a good way.
I love secrets, I love surprises
and why spoil the surprise?
- So given that the story
of the Breaking Bad universe
is still being told in 'Better Call Saul',
we're seeing the flash forwards.
Do you think we've definitely
seen the last of Jesse?
- I think so.
- Yeah?
- Yeah.
I'm such a huge fan of Better Call Saul,
and even before the
conversation of El Camino
existed between Vince and I.
I kept thinking, "There's
no way that Jesse
can show up here."
Like how is that possible?
Definitely not in a flash forwards,
I mean, why would he show up there?
Maybe he shows up when
he's in middle school?
No, that's also very odd,
and I don't look like
I'm in middle school.
(laughter)
- Few years shy.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But what they can do
with technology these days.
(laughter)
- There's not a chance
that I'm gonna be playing Pinkman again.
I thought that, but
then El Camino happened,
and here we are.
- And here we are.
Led us together.
That's great, look at that, look at life.
(laughter)
- Look at life, look at us.
- Look at us.
- Look at us all.
- Someone asked you, in a Reddit AMA,
I think, three years ago,
- Okay.
- Where you thought Jesse might be now.
- Right.
- And you said, Alaska.
- Yes.
- Did you know at the time,
that that where Jesse,
that was Jesse's ending?
Or did Vince sort of go on Reddit,
"I'll have that, sounds fucking great."
Like did you (laughter).
Which one was it?
- You know I pretty much wrote El Camino.
- It was all your work.
- Yeah I mean all the signs were there,
during that AMA at Reddit.
I always just sort of envisioned
him getting as far away
from Albuquerque, New Mexico, as possible.
Getting away from just that torture,
amd trying to find some sort
of tranquility somewhere.
And I thought Alaska would be just
such a perfect setting for him.
- So lovely, Alaska.
- Alaska.
- You once said once said in a GQ in 2012,
we're going all the way back.
- Yeah.
- That you didn't tend to go
back and watch old scenes,
or certain scenes over and over again.
And that you hadn't actually
watched the first episode
since it was aired.
- Right.
- Has that changed, I'm interest to know
since you said that?
Did you ever get nostalgic when you didn't
think you'd be playing Jesse again,
and go back and watch
some scenes or episodes.
- No I haven't really gone
back and watched any episodes.
My wife and I, we were
planning on re-watching
the series before El Camino came out,
and just life got away.
- Yeah.
- Don't get me wrong I'm
a fan of Breaking Bad.
- You say that.
(laughs)
- We're at about the
fifth or sixth episode,
it kinda went downhill.
- It's bloody bored mate.
- Maybe it's a little, I don't
know, it's a little much.
- So big question.
- Yes what?
- It's actually not that big.
(laughs)
I'm just gonna ask, what's
your favorite scene?
- Huge question.
- There are lots of great
scenes, what's your favorite one?
- My favorite scene,
its gotta be the scene
with Walt and Jesse at the diner.
I just think its such a powerful scene,
and how that scene ends is just
so, kind of heart breaking.
You know, Walt telling Jesse,
that he thought he was lucky,
that he didn't have to wait his whole life
to do something special.
- That was a fantastic
answer, really good,
really good.
(laughs)
- Thank you.
- So everyone knows one of the things
that Jesse Pinkman said
a lot way the word bitch.
- Where's my money bitch, bitch,
where's my money bitch?
Oh that's good, where's my money,
where's my money bitch,
bitch where's my money?
- You know just like on
YouTube, at the moment,
- Yeah yeah.
- There's like a three minute
video, six million views.
With just like Jesse's name,
bitch, bitch, bitch, bitch.
- Right.
- Is there a word or phrase that you say,
as much as Jesse Pinkman
says the word bitch?
- No.
- Really?
- I don't think so.
- No that's fair.
- I have probably been called bitch,
more than anyone else on the planet.
I get called bitch everyday,
multiple times a day.
- But who, do people just call you bitch?
- Yeah.
- Just shout it in the street?
(laughs)
Yeah they're like hey bitch.
- Oh its me.
- And I go,"Oh".
(laughs)
Actually I was here in London,
and this was years ago,
this was during the
airing of Breaking Bad,
and someone screamed
out: "Gatorade me bitch."
Because I was drinking a
Gatorade, and I turn around
and I throw them my
Gatorade, and they catch it.
And they freak out, and
then they go like this,
and run off just so happy,
and I instantly regretted
giving my Gatorade away.
- Yeah.
- Yo gatorade me bitch.
- So the last voice that we hear,
sort of at near the end
of El Camino, is Jane's.
Do you think that shows
how significant she was
compared to everyone else in Jesse's life.
- Yeah, absolutely and Jane
was the love of Jesse's life
and then heroin got in the way.
So their relationship started off great,
she was great influence on him,
and then it quickly
became a chemical romance.
But I love how it ended
with a conversation
between the two of them
on the side of the road
and her just simply saying,
"Look you have to take control
of your own destiny and go with it."
- And so he does.
- So you're also the voice of
Todd, from BoJack Horseman.
- Yeah Todd Chavez.
- So one of my favorite
shows, if you could voice
any other animated
character from TV or film,
which would it be.
- Aw man.
I dunno Tickle Me Elmo.
(laughs)
- That's actually a really good answer.
- No, I mean that was a joke,
but now that I said it out loud,
- Its actually not a bad idea?
- Yeah Tickle Me Elmo.
- A sweary Elmo, that would be great.
That would be great!
- I would do it, I mean I
would try to do it properly.
Like, Tickle Me Elmo.
- What about if you were
to do any other character
in BoJack Horseman?
- I think Mr. Peanutbutter.
- Oh that's a good one.
- He's so sweet.
- Okay so the last one, this
is the quick fire segment.
I have decided to call Hot Takes,
the name doesn't really
bare much resemblance
to the actual game.
- Okay.
- But I'm gonna ask you to choose between
two things and tell me
why you've chosen them.
- Got it.
- Just a couple.
- Easy.
- Cats or dogs, keep it simple from now.
- Dogs.
- Why dogs, why?
- I mean its pretty obvious.
- Dog people, lemme just say
something about dog people.
Dog people hate on, they
don't let cat people live.
They hate on cats.
- I'm not against cat people.
I house-sitted for a friend once.
It had a dog, and a cat, okay.
My friend said, "Hey make
sure to leave the door open
at night so it can go
out and kill things."
The first morning I wake
up I pour food for the dog,
pour food for the cat.
I go into the dining room
and there's blood everywhere.
There's little pieces of
flesh, furry flesh everywhere.
And I'm like, "What the hell is this."
And then I find a baby bunny head, yeah.
So this cat tortured,
not just sunk teeth in
and killed it and ate it.
It swatted around and killed
it and it did it twice,
while I was there house sitting.
And so, hence dog person.
- Okay I get it, that's absolutely,
that was a very good justification.
Maybe I've gotta be a dog person now.
Since you know your alcohol,
spirits or cocktails?
- I mean both, can I say both?
- Not really the aim of
the game, but yeah you can.
(laughs)
Course you can, last one.
The name Aaron or the name Paul.
- Wow.
- Gotta choose.
- That is a tough one, I guess Aaron.
- Yeah?
- Yeah because it's my first name.
Aaron Paul, it's been lovely
chatting with you, high five.
These are your Netflix nine.
- Thank you, that was really good,
it was really good, can
we take our nap now?
- Oh I'd love to have a nap.
(laughs)